and of course the entire dev team I
actually have to play it early version
though this game last year hit e3 and
I'm not gonna lie to you it was like
super alpha and I peed a little like it
wasn't even very good and it was awesome
so this is going to be incredible I
really encourage you to check it out
Egor if this guy you go fight is gonna
be on oculus rift and all the other VR
platforms is fall and it is playable
this week at the Ubisoft and oculus
booth so get down there and and do it
now now that we've seen some flying
Raptors soaring through abandon city
streets it's time to ascend a bit higher
in elevation so please welcome
Ubisoft red storms David vote if kheh
at Ubisoft VR is about more than just
technology it's about creating games
that just weren't possible before and
exploring new worlds with friends
without ever having to leave your living
room
it's about fully immersing yourself in
these worlds and going places and
becoming people and doing things that
you otherwise could not do today VR is
all about opening up the final frontier
captain's log stardate 2016.04.23 to a
secret testing facility
that are proceeding to our destination
and maximum
this is amazing absolutely astonishing
when I walked in I really wasn't sure
what I was actually walking into this is
very cool if I could have imagined what
I would have wanted the Star Trek VR
came to be this is this is amazing and
it's truly this brick that was an
extraordinary experience to be fully
encompassed in a world you're
interacting with each other and you're
talking to each other and you're taking
orders from the captain and your
eminence it's really cool
so there's captain's home yeah and the
engineer routing power and charging warp
coils annealing pressure
all right shields up
prepare warp take us Alex yes captain
game plane is not new I mean you know we
can play games with our friends but
there's something different about being
in a shared virtual environment hearing
that you're playing with you can look
over and see the person and see them
doing their job and talk to them a team
does not succeed unless everybody does
their job well chef decloaking
activate shields ok shields up shields
up I really did not want to lower the
shields I was very impressed by the bar
playing that game today
he really had the language of Star Trek
down and they are transporting Captain
looks like you see this makes you push
the buttons I will say I nailed being
the engineer
does he say it's a plane
Red Alert preparing to warp we're we
have been waiting in anticipation for so
long for the technology of virtual
reality to catch up with where we
imagine we should be and where we all
want to go please
we have full power and soon as soon as
you can get us the hell out of here I'd
be most grateful
this was really incredible 20 percent
buncher as soon as you can
it's your own star trek experience in a
virtual world where you can hang out
with whoever you want and that's a
pretty good deal
guys Givi Soph is bringing you the first
ever Star Trek VR game as you can see
it's amazing and you heard it here first
unless of course you heard it from the
reporter who leaked it on reddit you
know what you can suck a bag of ladies
and gentlemen here is the man who was
rocking the VR headset way before VR
even existed mr. LeVar Burton
welcome to the sofa had installed here
precisely this occasion thank you so
much so it looks like Ubisoft got some
of the old trek band back together I
mean like all of the old jet bands and
the new ones back together it was I have
two questions for you first of all I
know you have my email so why no invite
but we'll talk about that after and how
did the game compared to being on the
actual the actual enterprise so here's
the thing right we use our imaginations
so much right when you're on the set
yeah you guys know that when you're
operating the console you're breaking
all our I know I know I know I know but
here's the thing you don't have to
imagine in this game you are existing in
a completely rendered environment you
are on the bridge of a starship and
you're with your friends it's it's
pretty cool it's so amazing so what was
it like working with that particular
crew all of you having had real
enterprise experience I know I can't let
go the fact that it's not real but it
feels real I mean it felt real to us
when we were doing it but playing with
Carl and Jerry was amazing because you
know we have this special bond then just
like you will with with your friends and
when you play and here's the thing we
really had to work together to
accomplish the mission and what's more
Star Trek than that I mean you can play
as the engineer or you can you can drive
the ship you can be tactical or you can
be the captain but no one position is
more important than any other everybody
has to do their level best in order to
get the job done and that's at the core
of what Star Trek has always been about
from right and what people love about
cooperative yeah absolutely so when you
were when you were joining before you
were the engineers but in the game you
got to be the captains I wouldn't that
feel like well I told the guys at Red
Storm that I was not going to shave my
head
for the privilege and and so they said
fine for me it was it took a minute for
me to get acclimated because it was
weird how I just sort of slipped into
Geordi it was like that skin I just like
put it right back on again the lingo the
rhythm the technobabble it all you know
started clicking in coming back but I
was I'm used to like responding to an
order and not initiating the order so I
had to like oh yeah
engage that's how we start this thing so
it took a moment but I got the hang of
it and it's it's such a blast I think
that they really nailed it the graphics
everything it's so beautiful but you
will forget all of that
right because the gameplay is so
engaging god it's so cool I can't wait
to play this game preferably at your
house yeah you can come over and then we
can play we could play with like Brent
and Jonathan Frakes oh Michael door are
you doing like feelings yeah I don't
want to burst into tears in the middle
of this conference so I'll just cry it
out with you after but thank you so much
for talking about it today and you are
dismissed
but you can't dismiss me unless you
outrank me it's very clear that I don't
thank you but like many levels so I will
just say make it so number one I love
you I love you too oh my god